I think it's gonna work
all right yes
baby
oh okay less
let's get it
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
foreign
a lot to talk about today
I don't know we got
shrimp was indicted NCAA Women's
tournament massive ratings what does
that mean
succession is back
LeBron James is trying to get his team
to the playoffs
lots of news and notes and crazy stories
but I'm here for it I'm here for you
so welcome back
[Music]
baby
man you know what I forgot to do I'm
supposed to be on this screen I have a
whole new screen and I forgot to put it
on but anyways all the woo-woo should
have been on here
[Music]
whatever
anyways yeah you know I'm trying to be
different here it is I got my new you
know what I mean and I didn't put it on
anyways thanks for being here uh on
riffing with Griffin I appreciate you
guys
um you know make sure you subscribe hit
the notifications subscribe you know
twitch I'm on Twitch daily so make sure
you check me out on that support me
there support me on patreon you know any
way you want to support it's great I
appreciate you and you know here we are
we're friends with Griffin
um yeah you know love it
I appreciate you guys being here and uh
today's uh um
today's sponsor of the show is door Dash
doordash
get 50 off your first doordash order up
to ten dollar value when you use code
rwg at checkout limited time offer terms
applied that's 50 off
ten dollars on a 15 minimum subtotal and
a zero delivery fees on your first order
use code rwg that's riffin with Griffin
r w g
all right what's up y'all welcome to
riffing with Griffin I'm feeling much
better you know last week I was not
feeling well
uh
you know what I mean and here I am you
know here I am
um I feel a lot like I say I'm feeling a
lot better
um so I hope you guys are good I hope
everybody uh had a great week uh you
know leading up to this week
uh so first order of business let me let
me I'm taking off my headphones I
usually wear headphones when I'm doing
the podcast you know because I like
hearing how it sounds and that kind of
stuff but
I got a new hat
I did an episode of The George Lopez
Show and the lady was like they were
thinking about making this to look for
the character and then she gave me the
Hat afterwards we didn't end up going
with that but I kind of like it
so I don't know what you guys think of
you listening at home if you're
listening on like apple music whatever
you know you got to check out the
thumbnail on YouTube and let me know
what you think of this hat
um I'm gonna put a poll up on our live
YouTube audience
hmm
um you know it's just to see what people
think you know but I kind of like it
you know what I mean it's like you know
what's weird it's like I went through
the pandemic
and I was doing all kinds of stuff I
shaved my mustache I I was like you know
shaved my hair down I did all this stuff
but one thing I did in the pandemic was
I grew my beard out and I've never had a
beard my entire adult life I've never
wanted to have a beard first of all I
didn't know I was this gray that's the
first thing but I grew the beard out and
I was like okay face
it looks like my face has been made for
uh
this
you know what I mean and we don't just
look like it looked like my like anyway
it looked like I was a beard was perfect
for my face and I was like oh I need to
like this is this is my thing
um so now I said okay well now is am I
at the age now where I'm gonna be
wearing one of these hats am I a hat guy
now what do you guys think
excuse me what do you guys think am I a
hat guy now so this is like you know
what I think I mean I actually kind of
like it
so like I said I hope the podcast sounds
good I'm gonna you know because it's
hard to wear the headphones and wear a
hat so I don't normally like I said I
normally got the head I don't really
have a headphones on because I'm just
like you know I can say I like hearing
myself
uh but yeah I do look like a jazz
musician right like I should have a a
saxophone or something
uh thank you Janine for the Super Chat
and that's another way you guys can
support the show so I don't know we're
going to see if this is gonna be my new
thing you might see me on stage or I
might regularly start wearing hats like
this maybe I need a hat sponsor you know
and this hat is dope I love this little
whatever this is on the side here this
little you know Rachel's like iffy on it
she's like but I think it just depends
on the rest of the outfit like right now
I'm wearing this like crazy T-shirt you
know but like it's like if I have on
like one of my nice Tommy Bahama you
know that's my style now maybe this
might be
um
this might be the new look so you know I
could see with the pole the polls going
good I mean I put it up on Instagram and
a lot of people there was like people
who were like dude this is nobody that
loves you will say that that hat is good
so but I don't know I kind of like it
not that I care what you people think
but you know it is I guess it is what it
is right
it is what it is so here I am the hat so
I did The George Lopez Show guys I don't
know if I talked about it already I
guess I didn't but it was great shout
out to George Lopez and all the staff
and crew I'm not sure when that
episode's coming out but it's probably
coming out pretty soon sometime this
week you know
um it was great experience you know I
just just reminded me I love acting I
love working you know people ask me like
would you rather be a stand-up or an
actor and I don't know if that's a hard
one I love stand up
but I can deny that I love the process
the whole thing that goes into like
whatever happens when you're like
getting a job man that chase is like
it's it really gives me an adrenaline
rush like I love getting an email so you
know it'll be like an email from my
agent and they'll be like yo you are
you know oh you got this audition oh
like let me tell you about this one so
like
last week or two weeks ago
sometime around there I get this email
about this new NBC pilot
you know they want to I suppose I got
just producer session so you know it's a
zoom you know they're still doing Zoom
you know and it's I think also is
because a lot of writers producers and
stuff they realize hey we don't need to
be in the same place we could be all
over the place you can live wherever you
need to live and then when we were
trying to shoot the show we'll get
together but anyways so I'll get into
this producer session and I'm I'm
sitting there with the you know and then
I start doing the thing I've prepared
it's a good material and then it's the
director and then he's like giving me
some notes and anytime they start giving
you notes you know you're doing good
okay I'm just telling you if they start
to go hey let's do it again or
um can you try it this way uh if they
start giving you specifics like that
that means they like what you're doing
so and then like throughout it took a
while too so then he was like at the end
we were in a good place and he was like
okay can you do the first scene again
because I like the energy you're in
right now so it was like good I got good
complimentation to do and I was like yo
I hit up my manager I was like yo man I
know I killed that let me know so then I
get a call later that day from my
manager and agent and stuff and they're
like yo they want you to do it again but
can you wear a shirt and tie because I
need to look like a doctor because
that's what the show is about right so
I'm like cool I know I'm doing good now
kill it kill it kill it kill it right
uh then I do that that seems to go well
and then the next day I get this like oh
they loved you oh my God they loved you
but they're gonna take a swing at a name
this is the thing that happens to me all
the time
they're gonna take a swing at a name
uh
you know like what name's not gonna do
it love the guy that actually is doing
it I'm not even gonna say who it is
because I don't know if the show's gonna
get picked up or not so I won't even
talk about it that way but I love the
guy that they picked right you know but
it's just like you go anyways the point
I'm not even trying to be bitter about
that let me not get off track what I'm
saying is I love that whole process
that feeling that it gives you like you
know that step by step by step and
you're like almost there almost there
you know I just love that I mean I I
feel like for anybody that's trying to
get into the entertainment business let
me give you some advice some unsolicited
advice
the thing is is like
because like I'm a realist you know I'm
real with people like when somebody
comes and tells me about an audition
like my buddy Ben he's had his I
remember he had this pilot audition back
in the day and I remember him being like
oh man he was so excited you know he was
like uh you know the the Creator the
Creator he was like saying all kinds of
nice things to me and I was trying to
tell him I said okay all that's cool
but the only thing that matters is you
booked a job okay
so you know like that's all that matters
well you know he didn't believe me you
know he was like super excited and super
like all that you're like oh it just you
know it's like you know he didn't get
the part you know what I mean I don't
care what do people say it's what I'm
trying to say I don't care what they say
I don't care if their people are like
you were great you were wonderful I
don't care
write to check give me the job if I
don't get the job then it was not a
success now I could have learned some
things on the way but getting the job is
all that matters all the process that
goes in between all the things they say
oh you were great not I'd Rather
somebody say to me oh man I just
if one of the people involved in the
audition is like I hate this guy but
he's perfect for the job okay all right
you hate me good am I perfect for the
job great
but here's the thing though
that being said
it's okay to get excited
get excited it's okay to you know have
that Thrill of the chase of being like
Oh I'm trying to get this job and be
like oh man I had a great audition oh I
had a great callback oh man producer
session it's okay to be excited what I
think you should do is get excited
but then manage your expectations
get excited
but then manage your expectations I mean
I'm sorry your disappointments I
understand it right you just manage your
disappointments that's all I mean to say
so it's like you can have high
expectations and when you get
disappointed that's the moment you have
to manage that so because I don't want
to be a person that's just like you know
always like well you know it's just an
audition I'm not going to get excited
and you know I'm not like that either
I'm I'm saying be excited but don't it's
like be excited and then wait for that
process to play itself out and then when
it if there's a disappointment manage
that you know what I'm saying just
manage that disappointment because it
happens to I've been all the way to like
man you know I did a pilot two years ago
I had to go through all of this nonsense
we actually shot the pilot I made a ton
of money for the pilot and it didn't get
picked up so even you go through all
those things and then you you uh you
have this moment where it's like
oh man I'm gonna he's we about to do 20
episodes and this is going to change my
life and then you know it doesn't happen
that's really disappointing but I look
back and I go oh I enjoyed every step of
that because I did I enjoyed every step
of it even the waiting for the if you're
gonna if this Show's gonna get picked up
or not even in the waiting for that oh
there's something about that so anyways
get excited manage your disappointment
and then move on you know what I mean
that's just how I feel is uh uh the best
way to
the best way to deal with that
um so
anyways all right let's get into some
stuff I guess I should wear the hat the
whole episode huh until it's time to do
the the end I
think
oh man so all right let's talk about
listen I am not
all right listen I'm not gonna like I'm
not gonna get into any false news or
whatever I'm just gonna give you my
brief opinion on this but you know so
you know look at my new screen y'all you
like that so you know our our former
president
um Donald Trump is uh
you know he got indicted for uh you know
the the the the hush money payoffs or
hiding funds and whatnot
I don't know man you know I mean part of
me thinks like this guy already
the the former president Donald Trump
already changed how we look at the
presidency anyway just for being someone
that was so
non-political like we had this sort of
Regal idea of what the President should
be and outside oh they have to have the
certain kind of dog you know they got to
be they got to be married with kids and
and this kind of sort of like image that
we think our leader we want that person
to portray as a their character right
well he he he completely smashed that
you know I mean prior to running for
office
I think for the most part
even you know before he started to get
political we liked Donald Trump you know
he was on uh the the uh what is it the
The Apprentice his show you know he was
all over the place and he was with
rappers and he was you know what I mean
he he was doing his thing he he was a he
was a Democrat for whatever he you know
he flip-flopped with that you know for
the most part we were like oh okay you
know you like him you dislike him but
for the most part he was like whatever
right and then once he went into the
political uh realm then it became like
now we have to scrutinize him further
okay so and then he didn't he didn't
necessarily have the squeaky clean
freaky clean background of somebody that
we would normally say this is the
Prototype person
for
um
did I mess that up the yeah you know I
was doing it fast the the pro the
Prototype person
um
you know what I mean for for uh
uh um what do you call it
for to run for president you know what I
mean
you know what I'm saying so
it's it's just like like what what do
you what are you supposed to what are
you supposed to say like okay so so that
being said with all that right so you
got this person who like isn't normally
running for office you know what I mean
you know it's like
and then he he does it okay so now we
have to deal with a person that has like
a checkered past or like you know he's
he doesn't you know
what am I trying to say right now he
he
was running for president and he cheated
on his wife with porn stars
and he was trying to cover that up
the morality of that you can decide on
your own okay don't sound like a good
thing okay right
but I understand right
and I think that the people that support
him they don't really care
like I don't think that like if he would
have just if he would have just been
like listen
they already had to grab her about a
[__] stuff nobody cared they had all
this stuff about him nobody cared they
he he was already in the feeling of like
look I can say and do whatever I wanted
people seem to still support him so it's
like I don't think anybody would have
cared
you know what I mean
so I think he could have easily just
came out and been like he could have
told her like yeah I'm not paying you
off so if you want to say whatever you
want to say I'm just going to come out
and just admit it if he would have just
I I personally think that if he would
have just came out and been like look
I haven't been the best husband I'm
sorry
here's a couple of girls that I had some
stuff with and you know
take it with what you will I think that
he probably still would have won sadly
you know so but
he didn't do that and so he committed
some he committed on the books it's a
crime right and so now we have to decide
how important this is but like I don't
think people really look into it I don't
think people are really like
hey
oh my God I can't believe this is
happening I think we're so divided I
think we're so everything's so
politicized I think that the people that
are supporting him are going to support
him no matter what he does and we just
have to decide like you know then then
there's like other crimes that you know
it's like the January 6th stuff it's
like the phone call to the Georgia thing
where they have him on tape being like I
need you to find 11 000 votes like they
have other things that they that they
have on him that they're not even going
for yet they they did it with this I
don't know if it's a strong case I'm not
a lawyer I don't know what this means I
don't know what's going to happen seems
like it's gonna like rile up his base to
people that want him to support him this
might make it like like I can't believe
you're doing this to our guy who knows
what's gonna happen but it's like man
this is just a circus man and it's and
it's like this of the social media era
where people are just so much more high
profile we know we know way too much
about people I think I think we know way
too much about people you know
I come from an era where there was no
internet no cell phones no you know so
all we knew about the presidents of for
the past was that they were President we
saw them in magazines we saw him on the
news now that everybody's business is
everywhere
who can live a completely honest clean
life like
um
what I'm saying is like
people can look people people can pick
apart your life based off all this
information they have about you and they
can make judgments moral judgments on
you or not whether they're true or not
it doesn't even matter to me there's
just too much information about people I
don't want to know about my president's
sex life I just don't male or female if
there was a female president in the
White House and she was trying and she
had a side piece I don't care why do I I
don't need to know about it okay but
once you do know about it now we have to
now we make a judgment if you're in a
happily married if you're a happily
married couple then you you know the
moment you hear about somebody cheating
you're thinking about your own
relationship you're like oh no what you
know it's just gonna apply to us it's
like I hate watching [__] with Rachel
you know and anything that comes up
about that she's looking over at me like
you know man you know you know what I
mean it's like you're it's like you
cheated if somebody on TV cheated so I
don't know it just brings up a lot of
things it brings up a lot of like you
know
feelings about stuff so you just tell me
like you know I'm not making any
statements or judgments or anything my
only thing to say is like I think we
know too much about people and it
doesn't seem to matter you know and you
you ask the question should it matter
should this matter should like do we
want the president of the United States
paying off porn stars that he cheated on
his wife with
is that who we want leading our country
that's what you have to ask yourself
and then it's even more nuanced because
there are people who think well
I'm a republican through and through so
I don't care what my Republican nominee
does I'm going with that because I hate
the other side that much
is that the political world we want to
live in
I don't know
you know I just don't know so you tell
me what you think and then we'll have a
discussion in the chat
all right y'all
um what else we got here wait what does
this say unable to oh wow I wonder why I
said that said unable to add stream
marker that was weird Okay so let's go
into one of the things that's uh a big
oh no not that a big topic of discussion
let me go back to this screen right now
big topic of discussion right now is oh
you know what before we even go into the
big topic of discussion right now let's
let's get into doordash you know what I
mean our sponsor of the show I love
doordash I use doordash and the thing
about doordash is great it's not just
it's not just like you're gonna get food
that you want your hunger you're gonna
order from one of your favorite
restaurants one of your great local
spots doordash is like now they're into
like yo you maybe you made some pancakes
and you don't have any syrup you're like
oh no there's no syrup and I hate that
that's the worst but you don't got no
syrup in your pancakes doordash you hit
doordash up you go in there boom boom
boom there you go syrup comes maybe you
miss a knot on your favorite coffee
maybe you're missing some creamer
because you have coffee all the little
things doordash is there for you I love
the convenience of getting what you want
right to your door well with doordash
grocery delivery you can stock up for
the week or order last minute Cravings
conveniently look you've trusted
doordash to deliver your restaurant
favorites and now you can get groceries
delivered that actually delivers too all
right you you'll get exactly what you
ordered or you'll make it right sit back
and enjoy quality groceries just like
you picked them yourself want even more
value you can save all your groceries
and restaurant favorites with a zero
delivery fee on eligible orders with
dash pass membership get your dash pass
membership that sucker is great
get 50 off your first doordash order up
to ten dollar value when you use code
rwg riffing with Griffin rwg at checkout
limited time offer terms apply and
that's 50 off up to ten dollars on a
fifteen dollar minimum subtotal and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and make sure you enter code rwg
don't forget that's code rwg for 50 off
your first order with doordash
okay y'all
so we got
um some stuff to to go into so the you
know the Women's National Basketball
Championship was uh
this past week
um right and there's just a lot of talk
about
uh you know women's sports
and you know is you know about the
ratings and and all this kind of stuff
so you know there's this great let me
see if this works I hope it does let's
see me go here I got a got a new thing
I'm doing right here let's see if it
goes oh man you see what I'm saying this
doesn't make any sense I had this ready
to go and now it's not working
it's you know it's just guys I'm gonna
get this right one day
I mean
I am going to get this right one day
it's like I don't know why
I don't know why it's doing this I I had
it ready to go you know what I mean I
seriously had it ready to go and then
like now it's not working
you know
so frustrating this is gonna be great I
was gonna have my phone right there it
was like it was working earlier and now
look at it you know what I mean
oh there we go yes
there we go boom yeah
[Laughter]
love it see I fixed it y'all
Griffin is ready to go so so they have
this whole thing about the women's
basketball tournament
um you know and so this is like
one of the things that
um
people are talking about is like the the
the ratings of the the the game so if
you if you see right there it says the
NCAA Women's National Championship 9.9
million viewers are more than any
woman's
um CBB game ever any MLS game ever any
Stanley Cup game since 1973 the 2023
Orange Bowl 2023 Sugar Bowl 2022
Thursday Night Football so it's so this
one game got more ratings than any
Thursday night football game on Amazon
let's make that clear the 2021 NBA
Finals the 2020 World Series the finale
of Last of Us the most recent MLB NBA
NFL All-Star games
so that's
what
you know so that's a big deal you know
that's the big deal right
um
and what does it all mean you know what
I'm saying like
this is just delicate it's not it's not
even delicate you know first of all I'm
not going to get into what I felt about
like the the girls taunting the other
girl and you know whatever the thing is
the the the the the the LSU player
listen we have to as a as men
the the issue I have with that is that
we look at women a certain way and we
have this expectation of how we want
women to act and we have to just stop
thinking of it like that so when you see
women being competitive and doing the
same stuff that the men do whether you
like it or not like Draymond Green do
you like if you're a Warriors fan you're
gonna like Draymond Green and how he
conducts himself there's other people
who are going to be like I don't like
that I don't like what he does he's cost
his team okay but like we know that oh
he's that type of player and you're
either fine with me or not fine with it
because of uh you know your idea of the
Integrity of the sport right
um so we have to start looking at the
the women's athletes in the same way but
we put so much extra on what women are
supposed to do like how they're supposed
to conduct themselves and how they're
supposed to and in the same time though
in the same breath
you know it's going to be equal when the
women are being criticized for the same
thing the men is the men's are being
criticized for so overall the whole
thing is good because we're talking
about women's sports more right that's
just so that I think in that way it's a
good thing
trash talk and all that stuff I think is
good you know I just for me
I just I don't know man for me like I'm
just gonna speak for me when it comes to
like you know women's sports
um
like I don't like to look at things as
like it's women's sports it's men's
sports I'm gonna tell you how I like
stuff I'm an elitist I like the best
I like the best and I want the skill
back skill Gap to be as close as
possible
what do I mean by that I like the NBA
I'm an NBA fan because I like watching
the best athletes play I like to see the
highest jumping dunking running fast
dribbling fast like I like a fast
athletic game
that's I like I don't like college
basketball I don't even like watching
men's basketball I just I don't think
it's as is as exciting as the NBA when
the NBA is at its best I like watching
Steph Curry and Yana Sam tacupo and
LeBron James and you know John Moran I
want to see John Morant dunk over a dude
that's seven inches taller than him
that's the kind of basketball I like to
watch this ain't a male female thing for
me that's what I like to watch you don't
see that in men's division three
basketball per se either so you know
what I mean like like I don't even like
watching division one basketball men's
division one basketball I don't like it
I don't well I don't really watch the
turn the only reason why I even get
involved in the tournament is when like
you have a bracket going and you're like
betting with your friends and it's fun
that way almost like fantasy right other
than that and I didn't I haven't done
that in years I didn't even watch the
college basketball championship you know
I if you've been watching my pack
podcast you know I don't even I haven't
I've been kind of like on the NBA
recently but I'm starting to get excited
because the playoffs and the playing
game are coming right now right I'm kind
of getting interested in the stories and
seeing what's going on and looking at
some of the gameplay uh but anyways I'll
get into that in a second but
so I don't like uh I don't watch women's
basketball you know because I just that
form of basketball is not as
entertaining to me as the highest level
of basketball you know but that being
said
the product that they're putting out
is it a product of its own it's its own
thing and if you're into it you're into
it and so and it's great and so the more
people that get into it the better it is
for the sport and so I think that this
is a great leap for women's basketball
but like let's not get bogged down in
these numbers of like this one game
that's this sort of Super Bowl game and
the ratings so you know I've seen a
bunch of articles about this and it's
like yes the the TV ratings for
um
the men the women's they were up like 44
percent
I mean
this one game is great and I say and I
like I say it's gonna do a lot for
pushing forward the entertainment value
of women's basketball and making stars
and like these people trash talking and
people talking about them uh and and
they're gameplay the one girl with her
name Caitlyn whatever her name is just
this chick is done
she's done uh stuff that no one in
college basketball history has done what
her scoring and all the things that
she's done even men's women's the some
of the some of the records that she
broke so that's what you need you need
star like that now can that start going
to the WNBA now and then like uh bring
more value to the WNBA I don't know
we'll see but for now if the women's
tournament is going to bring eyes on
women's sports that's a great start but
let's not forget there's a whole season
so like I don't think this one game is
gonna be like okay so now the women's
sports need to get paid more right it
don't work like that the ratings for the
entire season you have to show that like
just a regular season game and uh are
they even showing it on TV it's like
according to like some of these things
I've looked up here like you know uh
women's coverage is still only five
percent of the entire that's very little
so whereas I say this is a great step
forward you know I think that let's just
temper our expectations for like what
what it means and like yes let's get
excited for nine million people watch
that NCAA basketball championship and
that's great for women but you know it's
like let's just temper our expectations
you know what I mean in terms of what
what it's going to be moving forward
because another thing too that I think
is great for women's sports is the nil
which is this like likeness you know
where College athletes can get paid now
and I think women are in a way better
situation than they than the men are for
like getting paid having endorsements
and stuff because they bring more to the
table they just bring more to the table
um you know look let's just have a 100
conversation let's have a 100 okay I
keep it 100 here on Riverwood Griffin
okay
if you are an attractive
athlete female athlete
the sky's the limit
I looked this up the top 10
most popular social media College
athletes eight of the ten are women
you know and it's just I'm not surprised
man you know it's kind of like when you
look at these Instagram models and
you're like who is this is she famous
for anything but being beautiful no
that's it that's huge so you talk about
you're adding that element of it you
know the selling sex you know what I
mean that's selling like Beauty
on top of being an athlete and selling
that so you talk about the female
athlete can now sell makeup clothes
feminine products all the stuff that
women buy when you watch TV during the
day all the stuff they sell to women
constantly all day this now female
athlete could sell that and sell Nike
sports gear uh sell the the idea of you
know being a champion athlete I mean the
sky's the limit for women to sell to
like you know sell themselves as a
product and and make tons of money on
the internet from sponsorships so and I
think that the more high profile those
athletes are they're going to be able to
move into uh you know the pro pro and
bring bring that because that's what the
male athletes are doing right now anyway
look at Zion Williams he had a million
followers on Instagram going into
college I believe and so then you he
he's already a star and now he goes to
the NBA and unfortunately his game is
not you know his body he's injured all
the time but just imagine the sky's the
limit of what he actually could have
done you know imagine of like Shaq had
he was already famous imagine if he had
the internet and all that stuff in the
in the early parts of his career if it
was the it is now
so
I um hello Chad thanks for being here
this is live uh but like you know
so I think that this is a turning point
that we're seeing so that one game is
helpful but man let you know let's be
look there's a lot going on dude the
WNBA has never made money there's a stat
about it you look it up man they lose
money every single year you know uh
there are numerous franchises in the NBA
who have won championships that have
gone out of business
like it's like it's unbelievable there's
there's a franchise that made one
multiple WNBA championships that went
out of business so we're it's not there
yet but it's going it's getting there
you know and so it's like just I don't
like having this discussion like as if
it's men versus women that's not what it
is you have to you know Sports is a
meritocracy Sports is like the best uh
you know regardless of where you came
from or regardless of race gender
whatever we care about the best product
and and then there's this factor of like
entertainment you know is this
entertaining
and there's a thing with with uh the
NCAA that it's not entertaining when you
know who's gonna win I mean for the last
20 years now recently it's been better
in the men in the women's game
for college but for a long time it was
like it's going to be UConn it's going
to be Tennessee and then like you know
the first two rounds of the tournament
in the women's tournament people getting
whooped by 65 points it's just like this
that's not entertaining it's like the
Haves and the Have Nots so that's not a
great product regardless of you know if
it was in the men's we wouldn't want to
see that we wouldn't want to see like
you know there's something about the
men's tournament that it's like uh you
know a first round game first round
matchup some somebody big goes out and
we're like oh man the parody and all
that the the that's why they call it
March Madness you know so it's just like
I think that like as that gets better in
the women's game it's gonna Propel
women's sports so
you know shout out to the women's sports
you know I hope to be a dad one day I'm
working on it and like I'd love to be a
girl dad you know what I mean and so I I
look out for all you know there's so
many studies also about like you know
dads supporting women supporting their
daughters and how it encourages I mean
all that stuff is important man so I'm
not trying to sit here and be like the
poo poo on what happened with the with
the women's tournament I'm just being a
realist about like you know we still
have a ways to go but this is a great
start so shout out to uh shout out to
the women's tournament okay oh I'm
running out of time man I really got
into it with that so uh you know let's
talk about some other things man
um
let me see uh yeah there's some crazy
stories in the news right now like this
is like this is one of these crazy
stories in the news let's go to that
wait no it's not that one it's this one
crazy stories in the news so this
YouTuber was shot after trying to prank
a man in the mall crazy story so the
dude's like he's one of these like you
know how Logan Paul and his brother used
to like do these like live pranks on
people dude this dude
he tried to do some prank on some
strange dude dude had a gun whatever
happened didn't like it and shot him in
the stomach dude survived so this this
is the issue because I know gun control
is like a major issue that's coming up
right now and it's like so this guy like
if this is a you know conceal and carry
but like just just because you could
conceal and carry doesn't mean you could
pull out your gun and shoot people
anywhere like there there are rules and
laws about that you know and so it's
like I don't know I always go back to
the same thing for me for me it's like
why is that the level of the technology
of weapons so that's just where I go to
this just reminds me of that so like
somebody pranks you you don't like them
the fact that you could pull out a a
thing that you could end someone's life
I just find that issue with that and the
issue is that the technology the
scientists the the gun companies whoever
makes weapons why have we stopped at
lethal Force why is that the level to me
there should be something you should
pull out boom he would be like oh get
out of my face he hits him with a freeze
gun or he hits him with like something
that makes the guy [__] himself just
something like why does it have to be
lethal Force I'm not trying to take guns
out of anybody's uh uh belongings I
believe in the second minimum right but
the Second Amendment right to bear arms
does not mean that those arms need to
have lethal Force at all times so this
is an example of that where I'm just
like damn and so then you start to go
two of like like like what what rights
do you have you know because people
always come to that like you know you
come in my house I have a right to kill
you it's like no no I don't think you
have a right to do that it's just that's
all we have that's all we have available
you know but again listen if you got a
uh a samurai sword in your house and
that's your weapon of choice and
somebody comes in and then you know you
have to slice their head off because
they were coming at you it'll be the
same thing as like shooting a gun I
guess right so that's that's bearing
your arms but you know
I don't know I think we should just do
better you know what I mean we got this
the AI these AIS they have out here
right now these AIS can uh you know make
pictures and and uh you know write
stories and stuff like that why can't we
make we so we can make artificial
intelligence but we can't make a weapon
that doesn't kill people
like what are we doing in society man I
just I just don't know what we're doing
like it's like everyone you have the
right to defend yourself I agree with
you you have the right to defend
yourself
that let's make it so people can defend
themselves without killing people let's
make it so people that maybe are making
a mistake
uh you know maybe that misunderstood the
situation isn't pulling out something
that can end someone's life
I'm just saying less raise the
technology
you know what I mean like let's raise
the technology man I just I I don't
understand why we're still at this same
level like it's like 500 year old
technology it feels like
you were shooting pieces of metal at
someone with lethal with the potential
of lethal Force let's shoot something
else
there has to be some technology that we
can come up with that's not that that's
all I'm asking for
I don't know what it is I don't know
what it is I don't I don't know what it
is like think beyond your your our
narrow thinking they've made us believe
that this is the only weapon that you
should have they've made us believe that
shooting a little piece of metal is the
highest level of technology I don't buy
it you understand what I'm saying I
don't buy it okay I think that they it
this is just a cheap money maker it is
the so now you have ammunition companies
you have gun companies you have
gunpowder companies like it is a big
business
to make guns what I'm saying is let's
make it a big business to make something
else I mean Elon Musk you know you you
got people who you know we thought gas
cars were going to be it forever and
it's the only way to get rich well cut
to the richest man in the world made
electric cars so maybe there's a there's
a somebody out there who's gonna be like
hey let me challenge the gun companies
and I'm gonna make an electric gun or
who you know what I'm saying let's can
we think outside the box let's not
continue to talk about it in this way of
like oh I have the right to defend
myself like let's make it more than that
let's take that off the table and let's
just talk about why is the highest level
of technology
for defending yourself why does it have
to be the potential for lethal Force is
there another way you know is there
another way to to to do that that's all
I'm asking you guys all right
all right y'all I want to go to uh I
want to go to my new layout and uh talk
to you guys about wait let me find this
um
let me find it go to state here we go
boom boom boom all right so here's some
like some stories and some uh
wait let me see so here's oh let me go
to this all right so here's one story I
wanted to do
um oh I love this this is great uh yeah
yeah baby I love this uh Instagram
account
um what's it called since this Instagram
um wait come on why hasn't it changed oh
my god dude it you see this is really
freaking annoying guys
like I don't know why this isn't
working properly
I'm gonna get it fixed next week guys I
promise you that
we're gonna have it ready to go next
week I don't know why it's like this
right now but next week I'm gonna have
this all fixed up
so there's this story I'll see now I
can't even do it here you know it's just
I don't know what happened you know what
I mean like it's so annoying
I mean Tech like this is what I'm saying
technology is like the worst sometimes
you know
this one you think you got stuff
just when you think you got stuff fixed
up this this happens you know what I
mean
yeah like why isn't this showing up
oh well I'm doing this live so people
are listening like I wonder what's going
on it's like I wonder what happened with
this with his thing I wonder why it's
not working it doesn't make any sense
it's like if we do this another time
Griffin don't do it live you know but it
is what it is guys it just it just
happens like that so anyways I'll just
go I'll just tell you about these
stories that I wanted to talk about uh
France
um France had this thing where they're
they're trying to like make people
um when they when they put something
online they want people to
wait let me find it they want people to
hear this here it is here it is they
want people to let you know so Francis
proposed a new law requiring influencers
to disclose the use of filters or
editing
like like that's crazy
I mean that's crazy so like people are
so concerned about the the the the the
editing of photos and stuff now
I mean isn't that something else so it's
like are you going to but like we've
never cared before I mean women wear
makeup push-up bras uh you know people
got lip fillers and plastic surgery I
mean there's no law for that there's no
law to be like you know uh you know you
know we've the people airbrush photos
you know their whole freaking life like
all of a sudden now all of us all of a
sudden now we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna be like hey you have to uh
you have to tell us what you really look
like I mean why I mean what do you guys
think about that let me end this poll so
it's yes on the Hat
right
I mean
somebody said that would be a game
changer for dating apps you know you
make me think I guess on a dating app
yeah I think on a dating app you should
probably have to do that right you
should probably have to like oh man it
still doesn't work God damn it yeah on a
dating app I feel like yeah uh you
you freaking told me you were five nine
and you know so maybe like whatever
information you put on like what if they
made a law like that so whatever
information you put on a dating app hey
that has to be
the information that you put
[Laughter]
oh here we go I could do it like this I
could just I could just do it I could
just do it online I could just do it on
um on my computer and here we'll do it
like this on the screen capture yeah so
there it is right there so it has
proposed a new lot you know so it's like
I don't know
I don't know I guess I mean that is a
big deal I mean I don't know if it
should be like illegal I don't know if
you should go to jail because you you
know what I mean like I don't know if
you should go to jail because you didn't
but I think there should be something
where it's like you have to prove that
you look like this right now
right like because think of how many
times that's been like an issue in your
life like when you know when when you
were like online dating and stuff like
that
is this like something you should do
oh it's it's kind of it's kind of it's
kind of weird man it's kind of it's kind
of weird I don't know how I feel about
it but this is like how technology moves
forward it's like how do we do this in
life right now you know
uh I don't know
I don't know I'm I'm weird I'm kind of I
I'm really kind of iffy on this you know
I'm really kind of iffy on this because
I just feel like
it's like we watch it's like we watch
movies and we know the people on the
screen they don't necessarily look like
that they're fixed up they got all
makeup you know or it's like CGI we know
this like dinosaurs aren't real it's
like you know it's like if you're
looking at the internet and you're
seeing someone and you're like
is this what this person really looks
like is it up to them to like why should
they have to like show themselves like
in this example that they're given right
here it's like ah send one picture the
girl looks like this and then like you
know fixed up you know it's it's another
thing so I mean I don't know I don't
know
I don't know I I don't know how we
should be about these filters
I don't know if it should be such a big
deal so you guys gotta let me know what
you guys think of that
all right here's another uh this is a
great account this this kid man
uh I need I want to show you guys this
kid man this this
kid is called miles music kid I mean
this dude this kid
[Applause]
this is really amazing I'm gonna go to
the velocity of all these bells
years old that's the pattern
you're trying to get your heart putting
on it he's putting all the music
together himself he's a little genius
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
let's quantize that to 16 minutes
not that much how do you spell organ
you're like a vintage vocal
whoa I am automating the delay here we
go
[Music]
oh man I get that kid is amazing so
that's my social media one of my social
media accounts of the week I think you
guys should take a look at it's called
miles music kid I think that he's pretty
amazing and it's very inspiring now the
other person I wanted to like uh show
you guys is
um
this girl her name is stormy weather
her name is stormy weather and she like
sells Beats and she makes Beats and
she's like self-taught right and I just
like in my algorithm because you listen
I listen to these music things she came
up in the algorithm and I just got to
give her a shout out y'all I'm giving
this chick a shout out because like she
is dope she got some dope beats man
[Music]
I mean
oh damn it we already saw that oh can
you rap on this
I mean right so give her a follow man if
you you know you wanna listen if she
sells her Beats so check check out her
uh Channel man
[Music]
right
so shout out to ice Stormy Weather
that's uh for her dope beats she sells
her beats and serves her stuff is like
copyrighted so I'm not trying to like
I'm not trying to get in you know in
trouble but hey guys Hey listen it's
just so we're gonna stay with the hat
you know what I mean
thank you for the hat and next week I
promise I'm gonna figure out this
technology
I just don't understand why I don't
understand why it wasn't working so you
know we're gonna we're gonna figure it
out by next week but listen guys I
appreciate you guys watching rear from
where Griffin you guys are always uh
supportive well not always but most of
you guys are pretty supportive and I
appreciate
you know you guys being here every week
I appreciate the super chats I
appreciate the you know everything that
you guys do when you come to the when
you when you come to the uh
come to like the live chat or or in the
comments you know I love all that stuff
I love the comments I love
you know
because it helps me get better and I'm
gonna continue to do it riffing with
Griffin every single week you know
so you know what time it is it's that
rap recap
if you want to send me a beat Eric
griffin.com Eric griffin.com
[Music]
tell your mom
and we did it again oh NCAA ratings
I'm stating
this game
it's getting better
like a shredder
let's go
let me hit this flow
Trump got excited
a riot
he need a diet
oh wait what happened to my beat there
we go I don't know
I don't know this week the rat recap
everybody
thanks for coming just keep coming back
watching the old man rap
this beat that slap
everybody handclap
as hell
I got my hat on and the beat is strong
shout out to music kid miles give him a
follow-on shout out to Isis Stormy
Weather
check out one of her beats dope and this
has been ripping with Griffin
all I did forget succession we'll do it
next week
yeah so look out for my review
my reviews succession next week hey I'm
doing this live man so I just gotta take
that out of the title
all right y'all
see you next week
move your feet
look at that skate skate skate
see ya
foreign
[Music]